[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the round table of
dim lighting man we're gonna look back
at our year the year that was 2019 and
we have each independently ranked our
top 10 moments most meaningful moments
slash experiences slash happenings I
like to refrain from using the term
meaningful because okay I'm gonna go
with meaningful is a part of it but I'm
gonna go with memorable because it was
the 10 that I could remember
oh and so I have a feeling there may be
more either while you're sharing your
top 10 or vice versa or just later
oh yeah I thought should have made my
top 10 so I don't like to make anything
definitive or comprehensive because I am
a I'm a human prone to error faulty
memory it sounds like you're hedging
yeah well it sounds like you're almost
pre apologizing that for someone that
you will have forgotten to be grateful
yeah yeah yeah
like saying yeah I mean I'm not really
doing that but that's probably my
instinct and also I feel like the order
is pretty yeah it's difficult
like the ordering was difficult I don't
know arbitrary it's not arbitrary yeah
there's a general rhyme or reason as to
why I put him in this order but if I
start thinking about it a whole lot more
they'll start switching around and yeah
who knows what'll happen I am very
grateful that we did this last year so
we did the 2019 vert no 2018 version
class number 28 now we're about to do to
2019 version usually every year they go
about one number of the years it was a
rewarding experience having this
conversation last year I anticipate that
this will be a rewarding experience
because putting this list together was
rewarding for me because it it forced me
to do something that it actually takes a
lot of work like I went back through my
photos and to jog my memory I went back
through my my notes that I had taken
like my Evernote Journal and I actually
looked at well I looked at my calendar
already I didn't try to be calendar but
I did think that man if I took a lot of
pictures of something like that we've
discussed that is definitely things want
to remember again I have at least one
picture of it I don't need a good read I
don't even like to think about it too
much because I think one of those
interesting about one of the themes that
oh no actually this is a this is a theme
that kind of I uncovered as I as I
thought through this is that man it's
like the vast majority of the experience
that you have with a particular moment
in your life will be in the memory of
that moment right so yeah the by far
right because something happens and it
happens one time you can run my night
but you will react sess that memory for
the rest of your life hopefully if it's
if it's good and it just strikes me as
man it really is it really is about the
memory but the memories that you for me
the thing that I kind of realized is
like that this year you know what I'm
gonna I'm not even gonna say it hazard
but it's about being in the moment and
it's like I started realizing that I was
sometimes and I wasn't sometimes I think
that contributed to my order
well let's avoid getting into it because
we got 10 we're also doing this with no
headphones for those of you listening
and I don't like if we're talking at a
different volume I knew you would hate
it I don't knew you would hate it I feel
like I like the way it feels but I'm
again I'm giving it a good shot I think
I have a theory as why you like it but
I'm not gonna say what it is because you
know it's not about that seems like yeah
yeah it said it's like you're looking
down your nose at me man no I feel like
if you have a sense you feel like you're
in a little bit more control and you
feel a little bit less in control that's
that's difficult
what's your number 10 most memorable
moment of 2019 after many years of not
being able to do this I was able to put
on a fireworks show on July 4th in North
and as I've discussed before this was a
big part of my July 4th celebrations in
the past I nearly killed my
brother-in-law one time and also a
random team girl I set a field on fire
and required a friend to come out of
nowhere with a fire extinguisher
you know I've these are all in the past
I've almost twenty nine twenty mile from
the freelance fireworks Hall of Fame
several times but and then come out in
the north to California you can't do
fireworks because the whole place is
just tinder ready to go up in flames at
any moment so going back to North
Carolina on the beach on a dock in the
sound and a have my father-in-law send
someone to buy a crap ton of very
illegal fireworks to just put on a
patriotic display of Awesomeness for my
family and to be able to do it with my
with my kids for the first time put them
in a little danger as well because they
don't get to be very in a lot of danger
hearing the very safe Southern
California so that was cool that was
cool it was really cool makes it to
number 10 on your list and you talked
about this in a previous year biscuit so
and I'm actually curious as to go
through our list how many of the things
that made our top ten have have we
already shared on your biscuits and if
so that makes me feel good because it
means that like the most the most emini
phille things in our lives who are
already sharing with you there's very
little if any that I haven't shared
boiler alert yeah my number 10 is way
back in January and what I I believe we
devoted an entire episode to talking
about my spartan race and our like our
most historic physical accomplishments
achievements and so from a from a
physical a compliment standpoint I
always got it was a peak for me ever
since then I've just been living in the
in the in the shadow of
of my of what a specimen I was I've
never you didn't do another one I there
was a lot of talk about doing more I
think I'm if it had the little metal
that was just a piece of a metal and
well you have to do 300 is like super
metal yeah I I'm gonna sign up you still
got a couple weeks you know what I'm
I've decided that I'm gonna sign up for
another saw another race something or
something or other and you know just to
gear up my training it really it really
makes a difference it's not it's about
the journey it's not just about the
destination which by the way was at the
finish line completely intact but only
by a thread I'll but I I think about it
a lot I think about a lot yeah you think
about it more than you did it as from
saying yeah yeah I only did it once I
thinking about it all the time I need to
do it more better do the right thing so
you can think about the right things
that's the moral of the story what's
your what's your number nine some of
these later like once we get a top of
the list I think I'm gonna want to
unpack some of these more especially
since that was the whole episode I'm not
going to talk about go back and listen
to that episode and then want to number
nine for me was throwing out the first
pitch at the Dodgers game oh that didn't
that was out on my list but it was cool
I was there for that sorry yeah I put
this on the list not because in them
again in a moment
I wasn't like I'm having the time of my
life this is a childhood dream come true
because it's not really throwing out a
first pitch of something that I imagined
might happen at some point but it wasn't
something that I look forward to but
it's pretty cool that we got to do it
and it's yeah and so that's why I put it
on the list because it seems like it
should be on the list
I mean you yeah I'm not gonna say you
you weren't nervous
you weren't anxious there's a word that
I can't come up with that you were more
than me about that I could tell it like
and maybe it's more that like the
sportsmanship Ness that of yourself
that's I don't really have yeah so I
could I could tell it was I got a real
kick out of it but I could tell it meant
more
you well it's like maybe the equivalent
is you know when I had the opportunity
to a couple years ago with Locke and his
father son three-point contest thing
that I think I talked about that you get
to do in his basketball league it's like
you present me with an opportunity to do
something to display my abilities I take
it very seriously and I actually was
pretty damn disappointed in my
performance my pitch basically bounced
and I'm gonna blame it on my bum
shoulder but you know I just was I
actually was kind of disappointed in
myself
which is I realize I'm literally the
only person on earth who's disappointed
in me
no one cares about it you know one aid
this no how was this thing I was proud
of us because no one out the flights of
our balls was in total units yeah yeah
and they criss crossed hey yours mighty
hit the dirt a little bit but that's not
for me to say but it was especially it
was a special moment in it in it kind of
you know it's a it's one of those
moments that you can be like alright
we've done we've done enough for someone
to think that we should throw out the
pitch at a baseball game yeah it had a
major league baseball game and they went
on to not go to the World Series right
that was your fault it's not our fault
maybe your fault mine didn't hit the
dirt mine hit the Miette
you know what I think it was your I
think your catcher was just more I think
you just reached further my number 9 is
my Thailand trip
are you surprised that's not higher on
my list those are your number 9 yeah
it's my number 9 here I don't know it's
weird now I'm gonna talk about why it
wasn't that great of a trip or something
it was a really great trip it was a very
ambitious trip and it was very special
but compared to the other things on my
list it was just it was a very ambitious
and well executed vacation but it cut in
my mind it's it just kind of was
and I mean it was a privilege to be able
to travel that far and to see so many
places and to me the big takeaway was
that as a family we did it it felt like
an accomplishment and I don't mean in
like oh we you know we traveled I guess
I kind of do we mobilized as the Neil's
we executed this this this trip and we
made it out a lot executed the trip is a
strange way to think about it is that
how you think about things it was just
it was also very stressful I think that
that's the thing that pushes it down
because it was ambitious it was it was
stressful for me like I'm I'm still
coming to grips with how I can really
enjoy an ambitious trip with lots of
moving parts moved around to three
different places saw a bunch of ruins
made a lot of great memories but I think
in it in the grand scheme of things and
in the scheme of my list I don't think
it it changed me as much as the other
things on my list including other trips
that I took and I that's how I evaluated
it we had a really good time our our our
view of the world was expanded I I think
that it baked something into the kids
that I didn't have as a kid which was
not just an Internet awareness of how
big the world is but a physical
awareness and I think that's really
valuable so I'll add that to the list
it's on the list I mean I'm not saying I
didn't have a good time I thought it
would have been higher myself okay yeah
because I'm not gonna I mean my my
number 9 my big trip it's a lot higher
up on my list okay that's all I'll say
but you okay but your trip was also it
had this built it had this well not so
many layers of meaning we're getting
family I mean you'll get into it yeah
you'll get into it what's your number
eight my number eight now first of all
this is another thing that I started
thinking I was putting together my list
so so much of this is trips right which
I think because
this next one is my Mexico trip with
Jesse that happened earlier in the year
the one where I took the infamous
watermelon suit portrait oh that boots a
completely blew up Instagram I mean
Instagram hasn't been the same since I
put on that matching short sleeve shirt
and shorts bathing suit I think you're I
think you're conflating it with when I
put on that watermelon it was way too
big for in my backyard and relaunched my
Instagram which should have made my list
that's my number 11 you can't do that no
my number 11 was i relaunched my
Instagram but I I did think that it
again
I don't know why I'm struggling with the
way that I'm processing this and I think
it's simply it's like if I didn't take
pictures of something I didn't really I
mean there's things on this list that I
don't have anything to do with an event
that I could have taken a picture at but
it was like going back through my photos
I was like oh yeah we went to Mexico
really earlier in the year it was
suggesting I had to get some time away
just the two of us which is something
that we don't get to do enough of and we
had a really good time with each other
and and then of course I did I I did
that particular thing of having that
portrait made which was just a goofy
moment it was her idea to you know give
me this ridiculous suit and then attack
anyway we created this moment that
became this fun thing that we could talk
about but that decision kind of it
created it memorialized a trip that
otherwise might would have just been
like a really good trip like me going to
Thailand well but the thing I'm trying
to figure out is and this is why my
number one is my number one right
because it is the it is the moment that
I feel like was definitely worth a
picture but it was the moment in which I
was most present and everything seemed
like there was like a moment of
realization like we talked about this a
lot we had a whole chapter in our book
book I'm at the calorie about it
stopping and celebrating which I'm
really bad about doing because I am
always moving on to the next thing
and so more of a go and accomplished
very rarely am I like regardless of how
well something is going or how awesome
it is very rarely am I like present in
that moment and this is common with most
people it's very difficult to be present
but that's why I put my number one of my
number one because it was this
confluence so this is an incredible
moment it's meaningful but you're fully
experiencing it but we're almost being
overwhelmed by it whereas a lot of these
things like that trip with Jesse when I
think about it the only thing that
really connects with me is the fact that
I took took that picture you know I'm
saying like I'm not yeah we had we had
good times and good conversation and
stuff but it's like seems very vague and
I don't remember like being being yeah
present and likes being like this is so
cool like we're at this awesome resort
in Mexico and the weather's perfect and
like we're together and like let's take
a mental picture of where we're at so
for me more than anything I'm actually
looking through this list and thinking
about how I want to approach 2020 yeah
bit of frustration more present yeah
yeah I mean I wrote I'd forgotten that
Chrissy and I also went down to Cabo for
like a long weekend I was like I was
like you know we should we should do
that again that was like right before
Valentine's Day right before yeah I we
flew home and then I turned around like
the next day and we flew to London to do
to go to VidCon London mm-hmm and so and
then we were in VidCon London for
Valentine's Day
so I remember we were we were not with
our wives and I was we were bummed about
that huh
but yeah I had without looking at the
picture I'd kind of forgotten that I'd
taken a little Mexico getaway myself and
it was very special didn't make my list
it didn't make your list didn't make my
list my home so I have lists to make
what number am I at I'm at number doing
eight I'm at number eight and I want to
save it until after the break because we
got a we got a we got to do some
promotions
and this is a this is an interesting one
that I gotta unpack okay
so length will be back with number eight
but first we'd like to let you know that
you can't pick up the shirt link has on
the outside but you can pick up the
shirt link has on the inside and it's on
what's on the inside that matters right
mythical calm place for all your
mythical needs including cool creative
iterations on our concept of mythicality
that we have tried to market like crazy
in forms of t-shirts bracelets hats
we have sweatpants we have sweatpants
that's an understatement because we've
got all types of sweatpants yeah you can
and you can match the sweatshirt and
wear it wear it you can wear a full and
you can look uniform your mythical
uniform we don't have any Rhett link
angles we need red link angles I don't
know
mythical calm rep your boys do what you
got to do and include us in it on your
body alright so now it's time to get
into my number eight now last year we we
both turn 40 am i right
no I turned I'm 42 42 I'm 41 yeah I
turned 41 this year you turned 42 last
year I turned 40 yes
and that was a big one for me but not
for you cuz you were already 41 I
figured it out but this year I turned 41
you turned 42 I don't know tell me you
turning 40 major 2018 list 29 a major
2018 design year 2019 yeah yeah I didn't
know if it it's 2019 my birthday this
year did not make my list yeah I don't
even remember what I did for my birthday
well don't say that because my number
eight is your birthday
frickin but seriously look my number
eight Rhett's birthday oh oh
I was don't don't you know yeah the day
yeah man I was talking about the night
the party when we watched your god you
forgot the part that was meaningful
enough to me to be my number eight and
apparently isn't
your list but okay whatever I don't
think about myself like that okay I'm
very self-aware at the beginning when
you felt like you were wrong in somebody
by forgetting something
well that's not somebody is me it happen
already number eight I knew I'd get you
with this and I'm just giving you a hard
time but yeah my number eight is on is
your birthday because that day we we had
the day to just hang out the two of us
and it was just we were like we're gonna
we're gonna go get some lunch we're
gonna go see a movie and then that
evening more of your friends and my
friends are gonna come over and we're
gonna watch another scary movie you're
gonna have your scary movie night but
the fact that we made plans for your
birthday for the whole day turn out to
be a kick-ass special day right there
was you had your first bite of a McRib
well we went and we you know okay let's
think about the McRib thing so you
wanted to get McRib it's your birthday
I'm like yeah let's go get a McRib and
we're on the way to the McRib and we're
like dude turn it into an Instagram
story mm-hmm and it was one of those it
was one of those times where it was like
I felt like we were having so much fun
that we just decided hey we're having so
much fun let's share it on an Instagram
story as opposed to you know we it's my
birthday we should really make an
Instagram story I felt like it was it
very much was that vibe and it was it
was just a lot of believed your own hype
good yeah so we you know I didn't like
the McRib but there was it was fun to
not like the McRib on your birthday
right and then - and then to watch the
movie but and I you know I mmm I think
you'll agree even though I'm not gonna
go into details but I think it that that
day of us hanging out was was the spark
for for ID ideas that we had later that
then
will lead to things that I I think it it
planted a seed that will lead to things
that were gonna be doing yeah without a
doubt
and I think that for you know we get so
busy being professional friends and I
think it was honestly it was a year ago
when we had a conversation that was like
you know we worked so hard it's what are
we really preserving time to just
cultivate our friendship you know that
was almost a year ago now when we were
having these private discussions right
right
or I can think of one specific
discussion that we had and then I think
that your birthday many months later
11 almost 12 months later after that
conversation well for me was a great
fulfillment of that conversation we had
it's like hey our our friendship is
important and it's not something that
can just be second to what we just can't
ride on the coattails of whatever we're
creating is gonna buoy our friendship
absolutely right
everything we do create does I mean it
it does contribute in a huge way to like
the vibrance of our friendship but it
can't be that can't be the only source
of it you know well and I think what we
I think maybe this isn't this isn't
necessarily in contrast to what you're
saying but also realizing that there
there is I'm trying to do this in a way
that doesn't spoil what we're you're
thinking about yeah but there is a way
for our friendship and our professional
friendship to inform one another more
directly meaning that sure we can do
something stupid
together that is primarily designed to
do to be an Internet video and we're
gonna have a good time but that's just
us deciding to do something that we
think will get views whereas there is
there's a way to be like actually the
starting point is our friendship and
then finding the content and the
friendship first is finding the
friendship and the content I think what
you're saying is that it's not easy to
find the friendship and the content
because it's kind of starting in a play
a place where this is work and of course
we're gonna do it together and we're
gonna have a good time why I actually
but if you start with a friendship and
we'll talk a lot about this at the top
of the year our first podcast yes I
think we can leave it at that but I just
want to memorialize as mine number eight
that it was just and I think we we were
kind of realizing it that day you know
that you were like we should do this
more often
you know it's like yeah it was it it was
it was a pivotal it was a pivotal day in
our friendship yeah and it was my number
eight didn't make my list now I regret
that it didn't okay so you can put it at
a half and you know I'll add it later
the commemorative version of this and it
right now
maybe maybe maybe one and a half maybe
oh you know all the way at the top I
mean no I make it eight what you already
have an eight okay okay so higher than
mine I thought but I will most you to
buy it to my seven another trip that I
took but this says there's a little bit
of a different way into this one so I
talked a lot about this I told a funny
story about my Colorado ski trip was it
funny with the with the family bring in
your boot where I left that dumbass ski
goggles no thing squeegee squeegee in my
boot all day and thought my foot was
dying I had a great time with my kids
Jesse of course didn't really ski so
it was me and the boys having a good
time for the entire week and that was
great that family time but you know the
thing that I actually look back on that
and realized this there was a
breakthrough there's two things on my
list that represent breakthroughs for me
oh I've got a number seven breakthrough
and the thing that happened on that
Colorado trip so you know I've struggled
with back issues that have that times
been debilitating and what and of course
I have like my stretching routine and
stuff that I've done basically every
morning for a couple of years now and
basically I am completely reliant on
doing this routine but there's an
aspirant there's a part of the routine
that I used to only do on the weekends
right because it's time-consuming
I had this lacrosse ball oh gosh this is
where he gets weird and I think is it
it's the size of a lacrosse ball
slightly smaller than a baseball I would
say it's like a rubber ball and my
physical therapist kind of showed me how
you can put it up here you know you can
roll on it and roll your muscles out in
the same way that you would with like a
foam roller but it's more of a trigger
point sort of pinpoint thing and I kind
of roll it all the way up my back all
the way on each side in between my
shoulder blades and so I know I've had
lower back problems and that's been my
most debilitating thing but I also have
middle back mid-back problems and I have
upper back problems right okay all along
the spine which I probably have
degenerative disk disease I've got these
issues and they and when I have
committed to doing something that's very
like trying physically like skiing for
six days in a row I always know that
like it's pretty it's not unlikely it
touch-and-go that I could get hurt and
then this whole trips ruined so every
single morning in Colorado I got up and
I did my routine but I added the the
like the trigger point thing and I like
was super precise and everything that I
did and took a lot of time and took
about 20-25
minutes to do this routine every single
morning and I had an incredible time and
my back never hurt once and then when I
got back home I was like gotta keep
doing I gotta keep doing this oh yeah
every day since that trip everyone at
the ball I've done the full routine The
McLaughlin method and it has transformed
my life you hit a new low I didn't
notice you hit a new level I work out a
few times a week probably bout five
times a week now but I was working out
two three times a week at that point and
a lot of times I would have to call my
trainer I wake up I'd be like I can't do
it can't go in is we would be unwise to
lift weights today because my back would
be screwed up and sometimes would take a
week or two to recover and it was just
really difficult to get into a rhythm
ever since that ski trip when I'm paying
this close attention to my back I've
been able to go in for both of my
workouts that are scheduled with my
trainer and then an additional three
sometimes four days going in and I've
kind of gotten addicted to like the fall
staying active oh who knows what will
happen right it is touch-and-go but like
I'm Squam doing the squats man I'm doing
deadlift I'm like doing like legit
things to strengthen every muscle in my
body without this spear that would be
associated with all this stuff back when
basically the last 15 20 years of my
life you want to do a Spartan Race I you
know what when you were doing the
Spartan Race almost a year ago I was
like I started thinking I'd like to do
that but I don't know if I could take it
but I kind of feel like I could take it
now I kind of feel like I'm in a place
where I could physically take it so I'm
open to it
hmm okay I just meant that
metaphorically I was hoping if I race
against you
Oh something fine like another training
partner because it's like I want to do
too much overlap with not healthy for
long Deana blonde Dean Oh blonde Dean's
with me man okay bondings with me good
for you and your balls yeah right I do
have I have
actually there's I've got balls
everywhere we got a bomb a backpack I
got a ball on the bedside table I got a
ball in my suitcase
who shows everywhere who showed you the
ball technique house Yvonne my if I my
physical therapist who was very
instrumental in all this huh shout out
to Yvonne no shout out to her you should
write her a note I thought about it what
about just mailing her a ball with no no
you could ride on the ball yeah you
could you could mail a ball
you really can't yep you can mail a ball
yeah I just put a stamp on it you can
mail a real across ball just right on
the ball okay I'll take it under
advisement my number seven is okay I
pulled a little chicane array here my
number seven has two parts because I
this was for this is a lando moment and
then my Lincoln moment was floating
around and it was like it fell off my
list and I'm like whoa I can't have my
lando moment because I got another lily
moment coming later so I'm like so I I
got a little notice yeah I want one
don't tell him he fell off the list
he'd involve the list because they're
both at number seven my number seven a
is this was the year then Lincoln and I
started mountain biking together like I
gave him my mountain bike and I bought a
new mountain bike cuz I'm not gonna buy
him a new mountain bike right I can't do
that when I already you know I can just
give him mine and get a new one I need
one that was a little bigger anyway
because you've grown that's been a
special thing over the this has been the
year of us taking some mountain biking
journeys together that's been very
special and then 7b is this is also the
year of me and Lando having special bed
time moment like my want to clarify this
yeah I took Lando in the bed every night
and then like I'll tuck him into the
under the sheets and like pull the
covers up to his chin and then like I
got in this habit of then like I would
then plop down and lay down on the bed
beside him on top of the covers and just
like talk to him for a few minutes
I don't know if I shared this on here
biscuits but I'll just talk to him and I
would just get a kick out of hearing
from him I remember I think I did share
on your biscuits where it was like after
the episode of GMM where Shepard kicked
me in the balls and then we had the
whole conversation about like that led
to am i acting on the show or am I
really
insincere that that was one example of
many of the conversation should have
made we've had when I'm just tucking him
in it was just a it could be five
minutes it could be 15 minutes of us
just having a conversation sometimes
whatever he wants to talk about but the
thing that really got me was I started
to notice when it got close to bedtime
he would be like he kind of tapped me on
the on the elbow and he'd like give me a
look and not his head like it's time for
me to go to bed so I can hang out just
with dad and I realized for him how
special it was because for me I I
thought it was special but as a parent
you're looking for those moments of
acknowledgement that what you feel like
is special they also feel like is
special and it's really rare because
kids just go through life not knowing
what's special then they remember it's
special when they get older yeah so for
him to start to treasure that and to
value that and want to go to bed a
little bit earlier so we have that time
to talk was just this is the year that
that happened and you know with every
day kids change and they're at a certain
point he's gonna you know he's gonna
boot me out and say dad you don't have
to tuck me in at all
what are you doing maybe I don't know
but at some point you should probably
violent airily yeah exercise yourself
like even he's 18 he's married Yeah
right and he settled down and home when
he's an adult but but this is the year
that and so for both of those things
that's that's that's easily my number
seven
well I I gave each one of my kids their
own line I didn't combine my kids into
one I don't want to do that to him but I
also put them higher on my list so I
I guess some of my kids come back I'll
get to that in a second but for now this
is more about me
number six is as I've shared extensively
and in an entire podcast clarity and
therapy I think my number one last year
may have been therapy I don't can't
remember I'd I therapy was really high
on my list last year because that was
the year that I started or I just
started at the end of 2017 I'm much more
of a rhythm with my therapy but also
it's kind of like all and the only thing
I feel like I've really done is I've
just sort of peeled back layers and seen
everything that I need to deal with I
don't know how much progress I've made
with anything but I've just become aware
of the progress that needs to take place
but the clarity the clarity that led to
me making the decision to turn into a
homeless slash Jesus person in terms of
my hairstyle that I explained in that
episode that happened this year so
recognizing that I'm always in my head
that I'm always intellectualizing things
and not stopping to feel things that
became kind of crystallized this year
I'm still in the very early baby steps
of actually making progress about it but
I think that I kind of there wasn't like
this one moment but there was just sort
of this general realization this year of
like I kind of understand what I'm
trying to accomplish I'm beginning to
understand what is the work that I'm
trying to do in therapy because it takes
a really long time to get to that point
can you articulate that or is that just
for you well no I mean no I think it's
just what I talked about on the podcast
it's about okay I mean the
oversimplification of it is understand
is basically feeling it's not that I
don't feel it's that as soon as I begin
to feel I intellectualize and I deflect
those feelings into rational thought
as opposed to being like no no I'm going
to actually feel this I'm gonna feel
where it is I'm going to experience this
I'm going to learn to communicate this
I'm gonna be able to communicate this in
my relationships and beginning to
understand what that might look like but
there's a lot of unwinding and sort of
deep programming that is required so you
know one of the things that I noticed
from all the touring we did this year
with the meet and greets is that once
once the momentum of you mentioning
therapy on the podcast started to
accumulate I noticed that people would
say to you in the mean green line they
want they thanked you for being open
about therapy and many people were
saying that they that they started going
to therapy for the first time and and
you had a big role in that
you know that was really encouraging to
me so I guess to to put the to pound the
pavement a little bit what's the how did
you how did you feel about that
um you know I actually gonna pound the
pavement alright I don't think it is but
I told I told my therapist about I think
I can't remember when it was but it was
it may be in been that summer tour and I
was like hey I want to let you know that
I had more than a few people come up and
say that you know they were they were
happy that I had been so open about
therapy and kind of removed the stigma a
little bit for them and now they were
going to therapy and it was helpful or
whatever and my therapist started crying
and then again after we get back we got
back from this most recent tour I was
like may I ask one less you know people
keep saying it like I I'd say in a meet
and greet line of a hundred people or
whatever there's three or four people
who will mention this and mm-hmm he
started crying again he's like that
means so much that's me so much yeah so
I mean yeah that that was it was very
special because I think that
I definitely thought that therapy was
for people who has some diagnosable
mental condition okay yeah and I the way
that I have I've really well in one
sense I think we we all have some
something diagnosable but I think is I
didn't want to say that because it was
gonna seem like I was cutting on you but
thank you but but but I think that yeah
it's just the way that I see it and now
understanding there's so many people
basically I know everybody's not in a
position to afford it or have the time
for it or whatever but it's just this
like it's as essential as going to the
doctor for a physical and which would
you give up first the lacrosse ball or
therapy mmm I thankfully don't have to
make that choice you can combine the two
save a little time I think if I didn't
have the lacrosse ball then maybe the
problems would become insurmountable
in therapy would just want to put it in
mmm but you're talking like Pavlov's
hierarchy of needs yeah yeah but so i
I've got some clarity and you know who
knows what's gonna happen in 2020 I mean
I will say my hair and my beard will
continue to be longer and don't make any
commitments it's artists you don't have
to it's really just take it day to day
I am already a little bit tired term
tired of it but you know okay but I'm
not gonna not stopping anytime listen
it's not admitting defeat to get a
haircut or a beard trim I'm not gonna do
this there's no judgement from me
I'm not gonna say anything I'm not gonna
say ha I have not reached my file form
yet you know what you know do whatever
you want to do and I also have not
experienced what I think are I have not
actualized you're not ugly enough okay
you gotta get uglier well that's gonna
happen no I'm just saying they I'm not
gonna cut it
hey it hasn't accomplished its purpose
yet
and I have nothing to say about it ok
what's your number or whatever
I you know what I will say though I do
have some say about it I I don't have a
therapist 2019 2020 is about 2019 is has
been the year for me to continually say
that I'm going to find a therapist and
it hasn't happened so but I'm I'm very
much in favor of it so I'm I've got a
couple of names and I'm sure yes I'm
trying oh really yeah I'm trying to I'm
trying to find somebody I'm not your guy
because I just don't think that's gonna
be a good idea some separation right
right but I will take a recommendation
so you should ask I have asked did you
tell me he he doesn't have a
recommendation he got us looking he's
like man okay I really feel like I gotta
get somebody really good oh yeah you do
don't let him and that was that was
where we left it ask him again okay he
didn't want it he didn't want to give
you somebody that wasn't good I kind of
want someone who's not good what who
wants someone who I wanted you know what
I want I'm looking for a therapist who's
not really good I'm not
alright gentlemen give me a good one all
right I did whatwhat number what number
am I on I'm on number six number six for
me is the London trip that Christian I
took with Lily for her 16th birthday to
the land of Harry Potter that really is
what it seemed like we did so much Harry
Potter stuff and again I talked about it
in the whole episode but it's one of
those things that I think again it was a
great trip but it was special because it
was it was just the three of us you know
and we may never go on a trip just the
three of us again so I will I'll always
remember that like I can remember a lot
of the specifics which I've already
talked about but so I won't go into it
but I'm so grateful that that we did
that with all of these things we talked
about these trips and all this stuff I'm
so grateful that we
you have the means to go on so many
freaking trips and and do so many things
it's like I almost feel guilty you know
the way it's like well you know when I
went to Taiwan let only made it not to
number nine you know it's like we're
we're so hashtag blessed but you know
I'll just leave it at that
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna apologize
I'm gonna be grateful and I'm very
grateful for that for that London trip
that's my number six my number five is
also related to my oldest child so Locke
and I have a thing we'd like to do
together we'd like to watch horror
movies and this year you know I if the
past couple years I've felt a little bit
guilty about watching horror movies with
him because he was like 13 14 but now
he's 15 he's a man you know this point
you can't just really screw him up and
so we watched hereditary together which
I'm not gonna see that for the final
like 45 minutes of that movie we were
just curled up on a couch like holding
one another and we watched many horror
movies together and we've kind of like
found our thing we're like very we're
very similar and sometimes our
similarities can create some tension but
we've kind of found that like this is
something that we both like to do and it
is exclusive to us because Jesse's not
into it and Shephard like has to be in
his bedroom with the door on and music
door closed and music on in order to be
able to he's not interested in any of
this stuff even though he's got a dark
sense of humor he does not want to
experience anything directly dark in a
movie so it's kind of our thing because
I don't really have any but I don't you
know other than my friends that I coerce
into watching horror movies with me yeah
on my birthday I don't have people who
want to watch horror movies with me so
that's been a special point of
connection for us that I'm like okay we
got a lot of horror movies to watch in
the next two and a half years while he's
still
it's nice to have things that you both
enjoy you know and especially if they
initiate like Lincoln talks to me about
like the latest hip hop release because
he's into that Lily the other night I
was talking I was talking last week
about waiting up for Lily for her to get
home and when she got home we spent like
45 minutes going through the memes that
she had pinned on her Pinterest account
because I was just like you have to
explain this to me
like just to cut what we're both into
the same comedy but that's not my number
five my number five the the the this is
a tough one this was again I devoted an
entire episode I believe to talking
about this so I don't have to rehash all
the details but when mom and my not
stepdad or father-in-law Lewis showed up
and then he was immediately transported
the hospital where he almost died was I
mean that's something that I will never
forget for all the reasons that I
articulated and then last week I filled
you in on how Louis went back home and
for the rest of the year he continued to
struggle to to to regain his footing
literally as well as figuratively so it
was like I mean that was a big moment I
feel like I feel like I changed as a
person you know I feel like there was a
lot that I took away in terms of empathy
and care I was a a large part of my
relationship with my mom was defined by
her having to care for Louis for the
rest of the year we would talk multiple
times a week just to get an update and I
would help her think through you know
you you get kind of in this fog when
you're caring for somebody you haven't
you they haven't been at home for like
months and months and haven't they're
they're on the verge of death and you're
trying to figure out how to interact
with the doctors and how to be proactive
and to be their main advocate
so that she's bouncing a lot of this off
of me and it so it really defined our
relationship we never talked that much
on the phone since I since I moved out
and it was very difficult but it was
also I'm very meaningful and I don't
think if if if we hadn't have gone
through together in person what happened
with Lewis here I don't know that I
would have been able to have a level of
empathy to connect with her over the
phone - I would have I think I would
have been at a total loss if I just
heard mom calls me up and says you know
Lewis had a stroke he's he's not doing
well at all and then she's giving me
updates you know what I'm saying
the fact that I went through that
Christina I went through that with her
really changed and expanded my ability
to be there as much as I could it was
still very frustrating because it was
just over the phone until I saw them in
July for that week we're Buies Creek and
then over Thanksgiving break but so
that's my number five that was something
I will never forget and I'm so grateful
that he's he's on the road to recovery
and he is back at home now
get him getting all types of therapy at
home to get back on his feet you're at
number four my number four is my other
child I it was you know I didn't want to
put one in front of the other she did
put two of mine on this thing I didn't
want to violate the rules of our little
yeah arrangement here and put both of
them on the same line but also I I put
Shep my experience with Shep higher
because I think that my relationship
with Shepard actually had the most
significant change this year
Shep and Annika I think we realized some
things about each other this year we
spent a lot of time together for a
number of you know logistical reasons
like you know needing to take him to
school or like just he's like I got to
go do this thing and you know there was
a he he ended up transferring out of the
school school that he was in and then
Jesse actually homeschooled him for a
couple of months at the end of last year
before he got into this new school and
that was not an easy decision
no was a big decision and so and he's
like great right now I mean he's doing
better than he's ever done but there was
it when he was being homeschooled
of course there was some days where it's
like you got to take chef to school or
to work with you because Jesse had to go
do something or and so we ended up
spending a lot of time together and we
did I think I talked about you know we
went to the we would go to like parks
together and we like went around and
trying to find that Fibonacci spiral
yeah and and then I think a lot of that
kind of culminated in this trip that we
took the Joshua tree that I talked about
I talked about taking the trip thought I
was going to take the trip but then I
didn't tell you about the trip I think I
just put all the pictures from the trip
on my Instagram and said that I would
but we had an incredible time when we
went to Joshua Tree went to Joshua Tree
camped at the same spot where I had
camped a couple years before and took
the same selfie went to Salvation
Mountain went to Slab City went to the
salt and sea together and Shep and I
have like we are on the same wavelength
when it comes to the way we experience
music as an example like you know I've
gotten this I've got this insight now
into like okay I know that little Shep
was gonna like this and like so I'll be
like any chef I got it I got a new
artist I want you to check out and it'll
be like Roy Orbison not exactly a new
artist and he loves it
Shepard will be in his room going to bed
singing Roy Orbison like he's playing
well he's playing pretty woman
haha dreams and he and he like and I can
see I know when he's gonna like
something mm-hmm so I start playing
where we over sitting he gets this look
on his face like what is this mm-hmm
and he just
laughs it and so and then we kind of
experience movies in the same way like
I'm a I'm a crier at movies Shep is the
same way and I kind of know the moments
that he's going to be crying because
it's the moments that I'm gonna be
crying but we while we're going down the
road going a lot of traveling involved
in this trip to Joshua Tree we started
listening to the podcast that was my
wreck last week Dolly Parton's America I
was kind of like okay he's 11 is he
he was enthralled really he and and so
we have sort of like like I said it's
not that like Locke wouldn't be into
those things in the same way but
especially Shephard at such a young age
like finding that like we connect with
the same stories and in music and in
that way we've you know we're it's you
find those things that you can kind of
you can kind of bond over mm and
especially about the music that like my
parents kind of introduced to me that
kind of like formed the way that I see
the world in a lot of ways you know but
it's isn't I it's kind of like what I
was saying it's cool to like the same
things but I also think you you're
describing something even deeper and
that's really understanding who our kids
are as people you know I think it would
always feel a little foreign to me I
don't know if if you feel this way like
I always felt like Kristie really
understood the kids I mean from a young
age she I always felt like she totally
understood who they were as people it
was like she could see the future and
see who they were gonna become and I
mean she was so she was so involved in
so many if not all aspects of their
lives because you know they did
homeschooling didn't you get that sense
from Jessie too that like in a way that
I just didn't understand I didn't have
that deep knowledge of my kids in the
way that Kristie did at a younger age
and I feel like what we're both
describing is something that and on our
list this year is being able to really
understand them as as people as fellow
humans not just as as kids but you know
understanding what makes them tick and
like how their what what what resonates
with their hearts kind of thing well and
I think a big part of it is we you know
we talk I can't remember exactly how we
worded this but we talked about it in
the book of mythicality about you fight
you finding something that you both like
in the way that that engenders this this
connection yeah it's just like I get
this and if you get this in the same way
that I get it and you're it's like if
you're seeing the color green the same
way that I'm seeing the color green
which by the way is everyone that's how
the eyes work but it's like you get it
and i get it we get each other
and it's sort of that triangle that
forms between a common interest and to
people and i think that our kids are
just getting to an age where that's
maybe more likely to happen and i don't
know you know if our the way that our
wives have connected with the kids is
just there's like a it's from a
different angle that will allow allowed
them to connect in an earlier point well
it's a it's a maternal it well i think
it might be maternal but it's also just
a function of how much time yeah i have
spent with them and they've they've just
literally schooled them right oh so it
might be like that we're just we're only
willing to do things we really like to
do so when they can finally do stuff
like mountain bike with us then they can
come along and we can have that sense of
connection maybe there's a little bit of
that but I don't well I mean I don't
want to overanalyze it but I do I do
think that I do think it's important to
find those things that you can you can
do together and appreciate together I
mean that's the way that it's what
friendships are made of my number of
let's see my number three will bring us
back to that but my number four
moment is our first bleak creek
conversation show in October we were in
Boston this was when I earned my number
two but oh really
but it's your number two well I put
Bleak Creek all things bleak Creek and I
have like three pieces of that yeah
there's three pieces there's the Bleeker
conversations tour
there's the novel itself coming out and
then there's the fact that we went to
Buies Creek for a trip what we didn't
like the the dock you follow series
where we went back to our two boys Creek
yeah padam number two so the moment that
sticks out to me is when we were we were
on stage and this was the first time in
Boston that we did this and we projected
the our trip to Buies Creek behind us so
we had the privilege of the the vantage
point of being on stage and watching and
hearing everyone's response to our trip
back to Buies Creek and it was the you
know the novel we worked so hard on we
were so excited about it was coming out
the next day they already had a copy
right there in their seats they're
reacting to us going back to Buies Creek
and the reaction was so thrilling to me
it was unlike I mean we've had a lot of
really special experiences on tour on
stage especially over this year I feel
like we've grown so much as performers
in a way that we never could if we
hadn't toured so much and and done the
three different shows that we did mm-hmm
but this that moment stands out because
we were just there as spectators and
they were reacting and then what you
know when it gets to the final one and
we're like talking about renewing our
blood oath and then the lights come up
and we shake hands on stage and we say
you know what this right now this book
and what we're doing the oath is
fulfilled you know it's it's a tangible
fulfillment of the oath and everybody
just started cheering you remember that
moment yeah so that's
a moment for me that's the culmination
of the work of the novel this was going
to buoys creaking how special that was
maybe deserving its own I don't know I
could have emphasized that more on my
list but it's it's all in there yeah and
that first show you know it's
interesting because I feel like the
process of writing the novel there was
never a real moment just because of the
way a novel comes together and then
there's the iterative process of editing
and all the steps that lead up to the
book coming out
there's no point that you can there's
nothing you can point to that really is
a definitive moment in which you're like
we wrote a book right right and then
there was the trip to Buies Creek which
was really awesome in and of itself
especially like the swimming in the
river you know I kind of remember it
kind of being being somewhat present for
that but it was really the whole package
of that coming together that night and
seeing it in the context of the
community of mythical beasts to me that
was the definitive moment as well was
that show was like seeing them respond
to it and I was kind of for the first
time watching it we had watched all the
pieces of it but like seeing it together
in context or we're talking about the
book and which bright lined up with the
day that the book the next day the book
is coming out yeah it just felt like
this is a this is the way to do it you
know even said that when we were touring
I was like if you know there's many
reasons that we did we did the tour
obviously one of them is well we want
we're trying to sell more books I mean
this you know yeah I think that that
being the initial reason and be like
okay this is a great way to sell more
books it became way bigger than that oh
yeah and in that it was like the
connection with who we are and like this
book being this perfect expression of
who we are personally but what we're
trying to accomplish professionally and
then being able to do that in the
context of community in this package of
this
film yeah that was a special moment
that's why it was number two for me so
and so and what do you are you singling
out a part of it making it your number
two uh you know I mean III said going to
the river during the trip was very
special but no it's really I think that
Boston show that first show was because
you know I'm quite honestly even though
they were all very special shows by the
time even the second show either the New
York show that night that we weren't
worth surprised by any reactions because
we it you know you know the points when
people are there's nothing like that
first time that yeah especially when
you're showing a film basically right
it's different than a concert but being
I mean the actual beam and Buies Creek
part of it I'm glad that you put it at
number two and I'm glad that you couched
it that way because and I kind of wish I
did because it was very it was very
special being there like literally being
in the river like that moment I think
cuz we had cross we had search for the
tree and then we when we were coming
back there also were like do we have
time to just swim for a minute and like
and they were like well we got to keep
moving you know we got a we're gonna go
we got a lot of stuff we need to film
we're like we gotta we got a couple of
minutes you know and they still filmed
it which was part of the thing but that
was more of like this is us just doing
what we did just because we we want to
do it we've come this far to come back
right that is a that is a big moment
when we when we jumped in the water hole
so is it it should be your go so now
that's my number three okay
so my number three is my scotland trip
you know I did the week in Scotland with
my with all the McLaughlin's that kind
of culminated in my mom breaking her
ankle at the Lachlan Castle and then
later realizing that I'm Irish that's it
I mean that has got to go down I mean I
said it then I'll say it again now it's
like I mean it's a big I think that's
the biggest moment it on air biscuits
that moment we
said that turns out we're Irish but yeah
you know the reason this one is is very
high on the list is probably obvious in
that it was you know this was something
that my thought about a lot I was like
one day I'm gonna take you know I'm
gonna take my family to their ancestral
land which really isn't there a necessar
land what let me clarify we are going to
do we are gonna do a follow up I don't
know if it's gonna be a full podcast we
have gotten more information about this
you mean you've got information as well
but you haven't analyzed in a very
formation right it isn't that I'm not
Scottish okay it's kind of difficult to
differentiate between Scottish and Irish
but you can't I kind of want it to be
that you're not Scottish because no but
I'm definitely more Irish you can get
yeah you can now you need yeah so you're
freaking you're freaking number two on
your list you have a baked in other
number okay number three you got a baked
in number three a years from now just do
it I don't know if my mom will travel
with me cuz you broke her aunt yeah but
you know it's interesting because
remember that when my mom did the lie
detector thing with your mom over a year
ago yeah and in that video she basically
said I wish you would call me more and
then I started calling her more I don't
know if I thought if I haven't kept up
with every two weeks like she asked me
to but it was it's more it's more than
than it was it's significantly more than
it was before that and you know we
continue to talk quite a bit leading up
to that trip and then of course when she
broke her ankle we were in even more
regular contact and she's she's she's
actually had a couple other medical
issues this year
nothing like super serious but stuff
that's kind of trying and annoying but
her ankle is basically better that's
great but so and from her perspective
you know she sees it as a as a blessing
that it happened and the way her kind of
her community came around her and
it actually led to her discovering some
other things that she needed to take
care of that she's dealing with but yeah
you know we just thought that group the
all the McLaughlin's have never really
we definitely never traveled together
but haven't spent a lot of time together
so there was you know my brother and my
dad and I being able to play golf at st.
Andrews that was a like a really special
day that maybe like one of the coolest
parts of that whole trip but there's a
lot of those like moments of must being
it like go doing falconry together and
then going to the castle right up to the
moment when the mob broke her ankle it
was beautiful it's perfect
but then after she did break her ankle
like I was kind of coming together and
having to figure out well what are we
gonna do now how are we gonna handle
this problem so it was it was definitely
one of the most memorable trips of my
life and probably the last time that
that group I mean you know now we've got
my oldest nephew is gonna he's gonna be
in college next year so it's probably
the last time that we'll just that group
will be together for that period of time
doing something like that yeah so I
think it I do think that it you know it
was one of the reasons that kind of the
communication and just the nature of my
relationship with my family it continues
to evolve like you kind of hinted at
earlier you know the Thanksgiving
podcast on the last podcast just the
nature of like it was different now that
we're out here and this the the level of
involvement like you being able to be
with with your mom and Lois when that
happen and it kind of changed the
dynamic in the way that you talked to
them yeah I feel like being there being
together for that length of time and
then being there when mom and Cantor
encountered that problem it's kind of
changed the nature of our dialogue
mm-hmm you know yeah in a way that I
think wasn't really the case like
movement you want sure you want you you
you're you're on the other side of the
country you know you can just pick up
the phone and talk at any time because
you're not in each other's lives it does
change
the nature of your right of your
relationship and that's your number
three that's my number three Oh cuz my
number two is what I already covered
which is my bleed Creek okay
stuff okay got it and then my so my
number three is the summer tour where
Lilly and Lincoln were able to come
along for the ride
literally riding on the bus sleeping
there at night you know helping roll up
posters I think at least technically
they helped out a little bit but it was
Minh we toured after that I remember
being backstage and I just I would just
miss them not being there you know on it
that's why I would like get on video
chat and talk to him you know when we
were backstage because it was it was
special to have him there and for for
them to be invested in something that
was that their dad was working on was
really cool and for them to think it was
cool enough you know um Lilly Lilly
talks a lot about how sigh you know I
really I really I really loved going on
tour I missed that and Gary was like
you've got the you've got the tour bug
but they both I like to think that it's
one of those things that would make
their you know their top ten list of the
year that they and I could I could you
know again it's meaningful when you can
tell that it's meaningful to them
so it was it was a lot of fun to travel
with him that way and to treat him more
as part of the crew than my kids so I
think it helped change the way that we
interact and the way that they see me
and the things that they'll choose to
talk to me about and the way that
they'll talk to me like I remember the
specific conversations that that we
would be having that then they would
feel much more comfortable interjecting
and like the way that you and the kids
would get into it with each other
something that was very special to me
because I could tell that they they kind
of rose to the occasion of being treated
more as as adults and part of the
so that was special and that was my
number three which brings you to your
number one so should I share mine number
two sure to shave your number one yeah
okay to even it out I'll give my number
two which was performing at the Ryman in
Nashville well that was my number one oh
that's perfect
okay so I still haven't mine number one
but okay well I'll let you take the lead
on it since it was your number one we've
talked about how meaningful it was being
to go to the hallowed grounds of country
music place where Merle had performed
and then to perform the two Merle songs
that we ended up covering and then
putting on the record for the mythical
Society that was just it was a perfect
show in a lot of ways right I mean I
mean we've had really good crowds and
all the crowds are really good mm-hmm
but sometimes you get of just a really
special engaged crowd I think they they
could tell how special it was to us and
it it was like it was like they were
sharing something that they knew was so
meaningful to us yeah and it's just in
you know venues are different and that
in that place is it's it's special from
not just because of the history but
literally the the physicality of the
Ryman the acoustics the fact that you
can hear everything that everyone says
and does and it just feels like you're
all is all the every all the energy is
focused right there into the middle and
I the thing the reason it was number one
for me is because when we were
performing those Merle songs and many
times that night I had this really
overwhelming sense that I actually
remember thinking of like it doesn't get
any better than this
hmm
you know I'm saying like from a while
it's happening your your yeah yeah yeah
from like a dream come true standpoint
of performing doing the thing that doing
the thing that weird you know we do a
performance for us is could be a mint
one of many different things right yeah
we truly we do a lot of different things
but doing the concert it's like okay
this is us at what for lack of a better
word our professional peak right doing
what it is that we'd love to do with
each other
for this audience that's completely
engaged in this place and then it just
hit me as like an you know what you're
really enjoying it right now like you're
really taking it in in a way that like I
just don't do I mean a lot of these
things on the list may be more
ultimately meaningful or impactful
because they were there to do with my
kids or my wife or you know my family
back in North Carolina but it was really
difficult to narrow those down to one in
one particular moment where it felt like
everything just sort of came together in
this weird almost mystic cosmic moment
in that I mean we've had some great
moments on stage where I was like okay
this is ridiculous bit become something
that you could never have written but it
just happened and now it's a special
moment in time just for those people who
came to that show and it'll never happen
like that again right but that was the
one that I felt like I was fully present
for yeah I remember looking at you and
then when we were when we were singing
the merle songs was britain like looking
at britain to it's just like having
especially when he had the guitar solo
cuz it was like i didn't have to do
anything yeah i mean you had to keep
strumming along but like it was that was
a it was a very easy moment to like okay
there's no pressure of performance from
me i'm like i can i was looking i was
looking at how much fun you were having
he was into it it's like you just and
that's the moment where I was really
savoring
taking it in and we talked about it on
stage and like you that became the us
experience and it became the experience
for the audience so like they became a
part of it and it was just a cycle of
energy yeah it it's weird because it's
like it's the one moment I can point to
on here where I can actually remember
what it felt like yeah
whereas everything else I can kind of
remember what happened and how it makes
me feel now but I can almost like
transport myself back to that moment I
was like I registered I was like oh this
is this moment is hitting me right now
whereas typically you're doing something
like camping with your kid or whatever
and you're like this whole thing is
awesome and I'm having a great time in
this moment where we're listening to
this podcast and I'm realizing that this
is a good thing we're bonding etc but it
really is the sort of taking it and
distilling it later as a memory and that
but it was like no it was in the moment
yeah and it really only happened the
accident is the one that can point to
it's the one time I can I can point to
that being the case well and I think I
mean when you talk about this theory you
know when you talk about therapy and
like being able to get more in touch
with your feelings I do think that's a
aspect of it you know I I feel like they
were I think so I feel like there were
moments throughout the list when I can I
can react cess the the feelings I had
and feel a bit of motion about a number
of these things on the list but yeah
that I mean that was a special one and
it's cool because it you know people
talk when you took any talk about
country music or like performance venues
it's like it pops up you know watch the
Ken Burns documentary on country music
and it's is so much of it is about the
Ryman on that stage you know it's like
it comes out of the woodwork a lot so it
wrote it it's a there's always an
occasion to be grateful that we were on
that stage again which is really cool
yeah yeah so that's that I mean that was
that was a number one worthy experience
for me but if I'm gonna get to my number
one
that this one's this one's related to
Christie this is a milestone that she
experienced that for me was just
vicariously through her excuse me
so a little backstory I'm trying to
remember how much of this I've shared on
the podcast I think I've only shared
I've shared the fact that like Christie
has she suffers from post concussion
syndrome so it's basically she has daily
symptoms invisible symptoms that
originated over three years ago when she
was walking into the grocery store and
she stepped up on a curb and just that
simple step up she hit her head the very
top of her head on a tree limb that then
she sustained a concussion she was never
knocked out she never lost consciousness
but she sat back down in the car and
gathered herself ultimately went to the
emergency room and got got checked out
and certified as okay but that she did
sustained a concussion and that needed
to watch it a couple of weeks later
which turns out is common with
concussions that there was like and she
took a nosedive metaphorically I mean in
terms of her symptoms got a whole lot
worse after two weeks and then lo and
behold fast forward three years later
she still has like I said symptoms every
single day of what she calls brain fog
where it's like like your head is
floating you have trouble concentrating
she's had a lot of issues with balance
and it's just dramatically impacted her
moment-by-moment
quality of life and it's one of those
things that it probably took it took
over a year to come to grips with the
fact that she has this condition this
catch-all label where you really don't
know what's going on within the the
mystery of the brain and there's nothing
you can
do to just fix it you know there's lots
of things you can try and she was trying
all types of things but she she went on
a friend of ours podcast and I think
that's that may have been the first time
that I mentioned any of this was when as
a recommendation I said you should
listen to the ask science mic podcast
episode 180 called living with brain
injury with Christy Neil so if you want
to look that up she in her own words
shares her entire story I think that was
in that was the middle of the year that
so up into that point you get her story
so again I recommend that you listen to
that if you know someone who's sustained
a brain injury or you you were suffering
from one listen to a science mike
episode 180 so she you know I I was so
proud of her in that moment where she
was able to share her story and redeem a
lot of the pain that she's experienced
over the years and hardship she's been
through and being able to share the
strength that she's found in the in the
midst of such a difficult condition and
there was the response has been
overwhelmingly positive and she it was
so she was so encouraged we were all
very encouraged to hear everyone's
response to it and then she was doing
lots of things and going to see all
types of doctors to try to to continue
to get better and slowly very slowly
over time she would she's seen gradual
improvement but I have I still have an
innate sense if I go into a space that's
really loud I kind of know the decibel
level with which Christy can't be there
you know that like she there's too much
sensory input or I can look at her face
and tell when it
there's too much going on she's having
brain overload that she needs a break or
that she needs to step away from the
group that we're with I'm sure you you
know you and Jessi also have picked up
on a lot of this at like but at a
certain point it's the type of thing
that you don't want to keep asking every
day how are you feeling because every
day it's I feel I feel like I feel the
same or I feel horrible I feel worse
there's never it doesn't seem like
there's ever many days where it's like I
feel better a little bit better it's
it's this trajectory that if you map it
over three years you realize I can do
things that I that I used to can do but
there's never one day that you ask in
the side well that's amazing
I actually feel fine it just didn't
happen it never happens so at a certain
point you stuck you know you stopped
asking because you don't you know it
almost it feels like it makes it worse
to ask when after years of the answer
being something something negative that
you're gonna get that again so it's kind
of sparing her having to articulate by
asking and she doesn't want to share and
she puts on she she puts on the positive
face and she she goes on with her life
because because she's got the strength
to do it but then there's this there's a
silent you know there's a silent
condition that's with her every second
and it's not the type of so I mean
that's and then we went we went to
Thailand and honestly I think one of the
reasons why the Thailand trip in
retrospect is like lower on my list to
kind of make a little sense of that is
the fact that it was difficult for her
when her symptoms kind of flared up
especially when we got back so from when
we got back from Thailand for weeks it
was like it felt like she had taken a
lot of steps back like she was feeling
horrible every single day
again there's no
can't point to any one thing but it's
like there's maybe it's the time change
maybe it's all the heat that we endured
there it's like you really don't know
but she was just doing worse and it but
it kind of led her to redouble her
efforts to find other things that she
could try in order to experience some
relief it was very discouraging when
after after two and a half years or more
things again worse you feel like instead
of better
but it's it gives tremendous credit to
her that she did she started going in
new places and and and changing her
regimen one of the things that became a
part of her regimen was getting in a
hyperbaric chamber where they they put
you under for four psi and you stand in
there for like an hour they said do it
like 40 hours and then we'll see how
you're doing you do 40 more hours in
this tank and the science says that when
you're when you're put under that amount
of pressure it it increases the the
oxygen concentration in your blood and
basically enhances healing of whatever
the case whatever needs healing right a
lot of athletes use it a lot of people
like burn injuries all types of injuries
that was a drastic thing you know I went
on eBay and found a used one and bought
it put it in our bedroom so she could
get into that thing because with such a
hectic lifestyle like traveling halfway
across LA to get in one and and pay a
fee to get in there but it just made
more sense to get one and I'm not gonna
say that is the thing that made her
start to feel better
a solely because there were other things
that were changed as well but and again
she didn't talk about this on a science
Mike because we didn't have it yet this
is after that was before the Thailand
trip but you know I I we do think it was
a major contributor to her starting to
feel better
over the last mmm
they're so - a couple of months and so
my number one the thing on my list is
when we were wrapping up the tour
I can't I can't remember I texted her to
first but you know I got her on the
phone and she said I I did ask how are
you doing cuz it's not like I never asks
it's just hard to ask and she was like I
felt great today and then the next day
she was like I feel great today then the
next day she didn't feel is great but
there were two days in a row where she
said I felt normal
like it was for the first time in three
years
she felt normal and it was you know I'm
getting emotional just talking about it
because I mean my ironically my number
one thing of the year is something I
wasn't even there for you know I was you
know wrapping up the tour a couple of
weeks ago but it it's it's been a
difficult year in the sense that feeling
so hopeless to to do anything to help
her and also to help mom you know it's
like the second the second half of the
year it's it's I just find myself in the
position of being someone who's very
close to a lot of hurt and it's you know
it's just it's it's it's been difficult
so it was it was it was great to see
Lewis back at home over Thanksgiving and
it was really great to to get Christy on
video chat and to see her face and to
tell that I could see it on her face for
the first time in three years that she
felt good and it it
gave us hope that yeah you know what
yesterday she had a migraine she doesn't
get migraines like and then today she's
like I still feel horrible I feel like I
have a hangover from having this
migraine which you know I when again we
don't know why and it's but we we have
we can look to these two days and say
there was there was there was this
milestone you know we can we can we can
cling to that and say somehow we got
there and you know let's add some more
days to that
let's keep let's keep moving forward so
to me that's the but because it it it it
it obviously defines her life and it
spills over to my life and the kids and
I mean everybody that is close to her
but just to be able to see just to be
able to see her have relief is was huge
so that was my number one well thanks
for sharing that yeah it's a I and I
think even even talking about it like I
yeah again I'm to go back to the
beginning of this I'm grateful that that
we have this exercise who we can stop
and say let's try to remember let's try
to remember the things that we've been
through to to be grateful and to know
how things impact who we are as people
and to be grateful that we have so many
opportunities to have so much fun and to
have so much so many things that are
rewarding and even the negative things
like what happened to your mom what
Chrissy's been going through or all of
those types of things shape shape us
into who we are and it's it's not just
what life throws at us but it's how we
respond to it and yeah I think you know
I think that the the idea I mean it's
almost cliche at this point to talk
about like being in the moment and being
present but I feel like thinking through
these these moments and in the things
that were the most the most memorable
the most meaningful throughout the year
in realizing that there were a number of
them that as they were happening it was
it regice regice Turing yeah and I don't
know I don't really know what can be
done about that you know and to just to
some degree it's like I eat it well at
some point you might be a little bit you
might be difficult to deal with if
you're just like every single time
you're experiencing something you'd like
it quiet and you everybody tries to talk
to you like you know I'm experiencing
the moment right now then you just be a
weirdo but I do think that there there
is it's okay there is something -
there's just something to having an
awareness you know to use an overused
term to have a mindfulness about what it
is that's happening to you
and if you can process in it or it well
I won't say or I'll say and reflecting
on it you know that's why I'm grateful
for this because it gives us an occasion
to look at the whole year and reflect on
it and say that that was a that was a
that moment was even more pivotal than I
realized
or or had the capacity to realize you
know there's the moment I think you're
talk about the things like being on
stage of the rhyme and it's like yeah if
you just pause for a second we would
know and we did that it was it was it
was kind of career-defining for us it
was it was so meaningful to us but then
there's some things that blindside you
and then you're just reacting or you're
going you're doing the best you can but
then taking the time to reflect and
process and say well what what did I
take away from this and for me I'm glad
so many of these things on our list
almost everything what was captured in
this podcast I think this
I think ear biscuits is first and
foremost it's for us for that reason you
know and then secondarily it's for you
to take from it whatever you'd like and
I think that's why I cherish it so much
because it it institutionalizes
reflection as a part of as a part of our
lives and we can always do more of it
and it doesn't have to be it doesn't
have to be on Mike
well and I do think is the one you know
we get to do we get to we get to live
our dream we get to do what we want to
do right and that kind of applies to
every single aspect of of our
professional lives like we're making
this the decision to be like okay today
we're going to we are going to eat that
these particular testicles of this
particular animal like we're making that
choice right at 11:00 every minute of it
but I would say almost everything that
we do can easily become work right it's
like oh this has become work but I think
since we changed the way that we
approach this podcast I mean I'll be
honest with you when it was an interview
with somebody it was work for me yeah it
wasn't that we didn't have meaningful
conversations with people but it was
like you know I'm performing right now
I've got it got to do this research you
got to understand what you're talking to
and ask these questions but now this is
just we're just a conversation and it is
the one thing that we do that feels the
least like a job and I do think it's
therapeutic until you go to real therapy
this can be your therapy
and I'm now I don't think that's healthy
I'm not licensed I say that right now
I'm we won't go that far I'm just a dude
who needs therapy who's been to
bi-weekly and I don't mean twice a week
I mean every two weeks therapy for a
couple of years but I'm not I'm not
licensed so you know what that's the
final frontier man what you think about
what we're both in therapy that'd be
good that'll be well we're talking
i-i'll keep you posted but you know
thank you for thank you for listening
hashtag your biscuits let us know I
don't know let us know what what struck
you what you thought about these these
things that we share this this this this
here biscuit was a little bit longer but
hey we're taking a break longer two
weeks two weeks we'll be back on January
6 two weeks so
yeah and you know thank you for to to
those of you I'm not saying that you
don't all get it but when I was talking
earlier about getting something like me
and Shepherd get this thing we get each
other many of you have made it very
clear both when we've met you in person
but also via the online devices such as
the Twitter and whatnot have made it
very clear to us that you get what we're
doing here on your biscuits and
recognize that it is special to us
I'm not saying from like an artistic
standpoint like this is this is like an
award-winning podcast but I think what
you do understand is that it is
legitimately just us kind of having a
conversation about life yeah as it
happens and you know and you and let
thank you we appreciate you appreciating
that it means a lot because we like
having these conversations but we can't
do it without you because I mean we can
talk good we could no we could talk I'm
saying we could just talk to each other
yeah but we wouldn't record it and have
it being produced into something unless
you had a you know you had an
inclination to enjoy
thanks for being there for us in another
year 2019 you did it
we did we did it we did it together
let's do 2020 together okay
do you want to close the year on a wreck
or do you want to skip over that is it I
mean there's a lot of pressure while
riding a really good wreck it's gonna
live out there for a couple of weeks if
it's a bad wreck you might as well keep
it to yourself i I'm gonna close with
the wreck okay all right here we go uh I
recommend this album you know it's no I
recommend that you
it took discipline to prepare for this
it took some time you know I didn't want
to do it at a certain point I was like
oh gosh this is seems like work I'm like
looking through my photos but I'm
actually thinking I'm like wracking my
brain to like remember things that
happened I recommend doing it we've said
all the reasons why so if you're if
you're on the fence just carve out some
time 30 minutes just like look back
through your photo-real your journals
your your calendar that's a good be one
of those people that like some people
they write heads do they write the
family newsletter and then they send it
out to everybody there are new people
who used to do that
I don't know any people currently do it
do it for yourself you know what just
make a list family dinner and share it
with your people I think again my kids
are gonna hate it
they're gonna hate it they're gonna be
like dad this is so Dom's don't maybe
start with top 300 or four things
there's gonna be doors slammed there's
all kinds of stuffs gonna go down but
I'm gonna tell my kids my wife will
definitely be into this that you got to
come up I'm just gonna say everybody's
got to come up with her top three
moments of 2019 and we're all gonna
share and one of them has to do with
your dad at least one right
all three good maybe two two out every -
two out of three have to be about dad
three yeah this is a good idea yes it's
like and then you have this awesome
family dinner at Chuck E Cheese no no
home at home you need to be a home
you know hashtag ear biscuits you know I
enjoy the rest of your year good luck
with that if you want to do it and we'll
see you in 20 2020 to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
[Music]